You know,
I grew up in an autistic family where
everyone was doing something in one
field of the arts or another.
I was,
I think 12 years old when I did my
first,
uh,
acting at the actor's studio.
And it's,
you know,
James De once said that,
uh,
the only reason to become an actor is
because you have to,
um,
I think that,
you know,
from a young age,
if that is a certain rush that you're
going to need to,
to satisfy them to make you feel
fulfilled,
um,
and if you don't,
then you shouldn't do it.
There's just,
it's just too brutal of a business most
of the time.
Um,
so I think that at the ripe old age of
12,
I figured out,
you know,
I kinda like,
I kinda like this thing.
I like talking to these people.
Oh man,
it's apples and oranges.
Um,
you can't really beat movies.
It's a,
it's a fun Gig I made.
It's nice to,
it's nice to have a trailer and makeup
and,
you know,
an entire army that's basically all
there for the same purpose,
which is make the best film.
We can,
um,
yeah,
when you're on an Oliver Stone said
everybody brings their a game.
Everybody brings their a game,
a from the top to the bottom.
And in between,
uh,
in terms of theater,
you know,
there's no,
there's no way to really duplicate that
rush you get when you take an audience
that is lot and right there in front of
you through the journey of a great play
and you go through these emotions so
that they can experience them without
having to go through them themselves.
It's a certain kind of human compact
that obviously you lose as soon as
there's a screen and the camera there.
So I think,
yeah,
I think we'll always have theater.
I think theater will always be a
powerful force,
uh,
because we need that human touch,
particularly as we spend more and more
time with machines,
cell phones,
computers,
we start to lose our humanity.
I mean the,
the,
the price of our technology may very
well end up being or humanity.
So I think you gotta have that balance.
Um,
personally I try to do one for one.
If I can do a movie into a play,
do a movie to apply,
um,
while at the same time writing and being
in that cycle.
Uh,
those two fields are very writing and
acting are almost diametrically opposed
in terms of being an actor.
It's in your interest to be in shape and
to be healthy and to have a strong voice
and to be flexible as a writer,
you're sitting in this position for
hours on end,
you'd get up and you can put your
shoulder down.
It's a,
it's not a healthy existence,
so to speak,
and it's probably not healthy for the
person that lives with you either.
But,
um,
I need to do the best you can.
Hmm.
I,
you know,
I'm probably most proud of,
uh,
the plays that I've written just because
as,
as the playwright,
uh,
you know,
your God,
you get to do everything.
You don't make any money hardly at all,
but you,
uh,
you really get to kind of control the
scene as a screenwriter.
You're the towel boy in the whorehouse.
I mean,
you,
you know,
you're lucky if you're invited to said
it's okay.
It's kind of like the,
here's the blueprint,
go.
Um,
and that's,
you know,
there's been some debate as to,
or not a film should be by the director,
by the screenwriter or by both
screenwriter lost out on that is when,
um,
and,
and theater,
it's absolutely the opposite.
But,
you know,
I'm,
I'm proud of all the,
uh,
well most of the,
theater acting that I've done,
the thing is to try to talk about a
performance that will never be seen
again.
That was only lived by the people there.
It's kind of like telling somebody about
your dream,
you know,
they'll,
if they love you,
they'll listen and smile,
but they can't really get it.
Um,
so there is a certain infinite quality
to,
uh,
to film that is nice.
You do the work and,
you know,
it's always going to be there.
I,
you know,
I just,
I loved telling stories and as long as I
can make my living doing that and in all
the different mediums that I,
uh,
I have been lucky enough to,
that's enough for me.
Um,
really it's a,
you know,
there's different scales of stories.
Sometimes you would want to tell one
that 20,
30,
40,
50 million people will want to see and
hear.
Sometimes you do one that,
you know,
150 we'll want to see on one night.
Uh,
as long as you're telling the right
story for the right audience and
they're,
they're getting something out of it,
it's essentially the same feeling to me.
Um,
obviously there's the economic necessity
of paying your bills.
And how do you do that?
10 years ago when I started out,
um,
I was kind taught,
I was insane for trying to pursue
multiple fields at once because in five
years everyone who just did one would
have five times the resume.
I would if I was lucky.
Um,
but I took that gamble because I just,
my gut told me it was the right thing to
do.
And you know,
as an actor,
there's so much downtime.
You want to fill it with something else
and,
uh,
there's a writer,
you know,
sometimes you're doing a passion
project,
sometimes it's a paid Gig,
sometimes there's nothing.
So he can do a journalistic piece.
Um,
at this point,
I think the shift started about 2008.
Um,
a lot of factors while I'm sure,
but whatever the reasons,
2008,
it felt as though the,
the combination of distribution models
starting to tighten and the publishing
and film and music industry is having a
revolution,
has themselves to,
to catch up and understand how this is
going to work in the new millennium has
made it a lot easier to pursue
multi-platform careers.
Um,
it's much easier to hire one person who
can do three or four different things
than one specialist in that field,
which is,
I think about the college graduating
classes in high school classes that are
coming up now.
They're in a unique position.
I mean they're,
they're entering one of the toughest
economies of,
of all time.
Uh,
at the same time,
if they're willing to work really hard,
the ability they have to learn something
and much faster than we ever did before
is there.
And it's really a question of are you
willing to put in the effort and go that
extra marks if you are,
I think there's actually more
opportunities out there.